you know all problems we make them
complaint cameras at them season two of
unreal is coming and we cannot wait only
et was on set as the hit show filmed and
we met the sexy new suitor he's black
and you want him dating white girls oh
please gonna be making deep dark nasty
love to them too yes unreal is going
where the bachelor never has appointing
an african-american suitor it's gonna be
great he's played by bj Britt you're
thinking should you mention my name in
the same sentence as Obama you could
it's okay um I'll Lytton you know that's
just me cuz I'm humble like that we also
got the scoop on the new crop of ladies
spoiler alert Tiffany's got daddy issues
Quinn and Rachel like to divide them
between crazies and wifeys what's the
breakdown this season way crazy they
have to really dig for the wifeys
they're constantly trying to make
somebody into a wifey % crazy twenty
percent wifey I'm going 80 20 yeah her
family owns a football team our suitor
is a pro football player I think wifey
yes hashtag wifey what is the Quinn and
Rachel depiction of her you know they
would call her a black de vez but I'd
like to think she's a little bit more
than you want so that in Quinn and
Rachel terms well she almost becomes a
wifey but she doesn't she is sort of
classified as a hot Rachel which gets a
little controversial we are having our
first african-american suitor on unreal
and can you believe that they haven't
had one on The Bachelor yet though don't
even get me started yes it's about time
it's 2016 unreal season 2 premieres June
sixth on lifetime check out etonline
calm for even more including our
exclusive interviews with stars
constance zimmer and shiri appleby
you